why is it that I can't override that
impulse and through sheer force of will
like Marshall my mental and emotional
powers to prevent myself from doing that
thing that I am so lured to yeah it
sounds pretty good doesn't it you know
where these rational thinking beings I
think Descartes really sent us down a
path that was not so good you know oh
I'm thinking therefore I can think my
way through stuff it's not how our
brains work yeah you know the there's a
part of the brain the prefrontal cortex
that that's involved in in willpower
it's the weakest part of the brain from
an evolutionary perspective it's the
first that goes offline when we're
stressed when we're angry when we're sad
when we're tired you know that's why we
wander into the kitchen late at night
looking for something because we've
learned that and so we can say don't do
that but then we just crash harder you
know and in the morning we set that
resolve to like okay I'm really gonna do
it this time but that's just not how our
brains work